- Gary who's your
second in command?
- At VaynerMedia today?
- Sure.
- I would say
it's Claude Silver.
She's our chief heart officer.
I think when you're, when you
have 700 employees and you're
selling people that's the asset
and so when you were talking
about culture I was laughing
because you're like,
"It's awesome," I'm like
"I wonder what the
other 5000 people think."
Right, because culture is
a one person thing.
And so when I think about
culture, I'm sure you agree,
I know that we're trying so so
hard, way, way more than the
norm but I don't know
what it means to all 700.
We ask and
we're counterpunchers.
We don't push it.
We respond to it.
And so at Vayner, it's Claude
Silver as chief heart officer.
Then I would say it's
James Orsini who's our
chief operating officer.
- What's a bigger business?
Wine Library or Vaynermedia?
- VaynerMedia.
- And so I watched you
grow that from 12 people.
- Yep.
- That was the first time
we kind of worked together.
- That's right.
- And I've kind of understood
some of the pain
you've gone through.
What's been the
hardest thing about that?
Actually, what I really
want to say is
you've operated smaller businesses,
what's it like to actually run?
When you walk into the new
space you're blown away.
What is it like to
operate that kinds of business?
- So far, so good.
The hardest part and have what
it feels like is the same answer
which is how do you
get buy-in at scale?
It's a lot easier to get 30
people to buy in to you and your
vision than it is 500 and 700.
That's fun for me to see four or
five of in them here and they're
all in different parts of their
career at Vayner right now,
in different
challenges or opportunities.
- You ever have to think about
mapping people's careers before?
- I've always
thought about that.
I literally reverse
engineer every single person.
I have context on how they came
from, the conversations we've
had, who their mentors were
before, what they thought.
Emily's mom thought that
we were some mafioso thing.
(audience laughter)
I know who Sam's mentor was.
I understand where Lisa worked
in a traditional
agency for 14 years.
I know that Garrett went to
the same school as my children.
I know shit.
Like I am the head of
HR, CEO and so always.
Wine Library, VaynerMedia and
everything I do forever it's
only a people game
everything else continues to get
commoditized by technology.
This is a human thing.
We are humans, we are
the ultimate species.
We've won, it's us and
we are the game and
so yes I have
thought about that.
I think the reason we built one
of the fastest growing agencies
ever is because of
that part of it and
the biggest challenge
was getting buy-in.
Knowing that at 200 people there
were so many people that didn't
believe me that thought tomorrow
I'm gonna do something bad or
I'm doing this because I want
to buy the Jets and I don't care
about them or
whatever it may be.
It's been a lot of fun for
me because now we're a little
further along and everybody
who's been waiting every day
that it doesn't switch, it
doesn't turn, it doesn't become
about the money they aren't
forced to do things, we keep
listening you know it's
like gaining trust, right?
And so now we've got, we are
much tighter and stronger at 700
than we were at 250 which is
usually the other way but that's
what happens when you
actually doubled down on it.
And when the stories translate
and it's not always perfect.
Even the people in this room,
it's not clicking perfectly
right this second but
you put in the effort.
You put in the effort.
You play a forever game.
You treat them just as well on
the way out and forever and help
it's a people game.
Yeah I've always thought that
it's really the only
move I've got.
- I can attest to that.
(hip hop music)